[Music]
as we probably know Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen is
one of the most anticipated anime right
now who doesn't want to watch thrilling
battles and spine tingling curses but
have you ever wondered which moments
left a lasting impact on fans and
critics alike from Utah's insane
power-ups to Gojo's or inspiring display
of Limitless power this is our list of
the top 20 moments in jiujitsu Kaizen
first up on our list is one of the most
unforgettable simple short battles in
jiu Jutsu Kaizen Mari versus
mea Nea thought it would be an easy
fight initially brushing off Mari is
weak but oh boy how she was wrong using
that Split Second Mari rushes with full
force she overpowers her and she disarms
mea quite easily but what truly makes
this scene a stand out is the character
growth and the action Mar's pole arm
skills are nothing short of spectacular
that 360° swing is like a legendary
combo move when it lands you can't help
but Shout with excitement it's the kind
of moment that gets the adrenaline
pumping but what adds depth to this
battle is Mar's strategic Brilliance
breaking her weapon into two and
throwing it towards mea to distract her
is simply marvelous also with the iido
tactic you can easily see how good the
choreography is in that scene this is
like one of those I can't believe that
just happened moment that just keeps us
coming back for
more
next on the list from the jiujitsu
Kaizen zero film Gojo versus
Miguel this is one of the fights that
showcases Gojo's incredible physical
abilities where he rarely used his curse
technique Miguel decides to challenge
Gojo but it's clear from the get-go that
he's way out of his League then it just
shows how unfair the battle is as Gojo
easily backhand Miguel's supposed
overpowered whip like it's nobody's
business Miguel was boasting that he
killed Sorcerers for decades but then
here he is getting beaten to a pulp if
Gojo wasn't in a hurry he probably would
have mocked Miguel for challenging him
after Gojo gracefully Dodges Miguel's
swings he should have realized that he's
clearly outsmarted then comes the slap
followed by a kick combo that slap
though Gojo literally slapped the goofy
out of him and don't forget that kick
it's like Miguel's head disappeared for
a moment Miguel attempts to slow Gojo
down with curses but it's futile
although Miguel is there to stall Gojo
for some time surviving that beating
from one of the strongest if not the
strongest being in the verse was a
miracle in
itself moving on we have one of the best
opening fight scenes in all of anime
Gojo versus suuna in episode
one
now you wouldn't normally expect this
kind of Face Off from the top bosses in
the series to appear in episode one of
the anime considering that sukuna is
just possessing yuji's body and is still
so weak this fight brought us a glimpse
of the potential of Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen
along with hopefully the best one-on-one
fight that's about to come but let's
talk about how Gojo pissed off sukuna by
casually blurting that he's the
strongest while stretching which was
both cold and disrespectful sukuna
immediately takes over yuji's body and
attack but Gojo really did suku NTI in
this fight he easily Dodges and sits on
his back like he's playing with a child
this scene gives the audience an idea as
to why Gojo was called the strongest
sorcerer in his time and how impactful
he'll be in the entire
[Music]
series up next megumi invoked his hidden
trump card the cha Shadow Garden to
fight off against the finger
Bearer
now why is this scene such a gem well
aside from the fact that it looks like a
raven the upside down megumi's control
over this domain may not be perfect but
we finally saw his true potential and
why sukuna was so interested in him he's
basically the Puppet Master of the
Shadow realm and his opponent is just
trying not to trip over their own feet
the scene gains depth from the name of
megumi's domain chimira Shadow Garden
the term kimira suggests something one
wishes for but appears elusory or nearly
impossible to attain initially megumi
thought that kima's Shadow Garden was
unattainable a distant dream or nothing
but a mere illusion but his vivid
imagination and profound Mastery of his
cursed technique led him to manifest his
domain which helped him defeat a special
grade spirit all on his own the way we
saw megumi become crazy like a rabid
animal was something we thought we'd
never get to witness considering his
attitude
[Music]
coming up we have a fight between Gojo
and Joo now you might be confused by the
names but not by who the winner
is this scene is more than just a battle
it's a display of Gojo's domination the
very idea of tension or a back and forth
struggle is laughable because well in
reality Gojo had this match in the bag
before he even set foot in the ring in
fact Gojo's victory was so assured that
he didn't even need to remove his
signature eye cover but Gojo being the
stylish sorcerer that he is didn't
settle for a simple win instead he
turned this fight into a lesson on
domain expansions for Yuji using poor
joogo as a real world example in the
beginning no matter what Joo threw at
Gojo it didn't hit and he realized that
his arrogance was just about to lead to
his demise as the fight went on we also
got to witness just how strong and
overpowered domain expansions were the
animation was spectacular especially
with Gojo's unlimited void even if Joe
go through everything he had labeling
this encounter as a fight is quite
unfair for the one above all
[Music]
Gojo blitzing in at number 15 is a scene
that surprised everyone who saw it Utah
copies inum maki's Cur speech
technique
Utah's ability to replicate inumaki
cursed speech technique after merely
observing it raises numerous questions
and adds an element of mystery to the
series inari's curse technique isn't a
straightforward ability it comes with
specific requirements and complexities
and it can only be used by Sorcerers
from his clan what makes this scene
particularly intriguing is the absence
of a clear explanation UTA using the
inumaki Clan's cursed speech without any
negative effects goes against the usual
jiujitsu verse rules the way it took the
Audience by surprise the impact and then
the hype after it was all worth watching
best of all utat uses the word die a
word that not even inumaki used in the
entirety of the
series moving on let's talk about the
Epic Beatdown between Kento nanami and
haruta shigo during the Shibuya
Arc
nanami the formidable grade one sorcerer
steps into the scene and locks eyes with
haruta shigo in an instant he creates a
weak point on sho's face and delivers a
slash that you could probably hear
echoing in the next District after
hitting him two more times if it wasn't
for his cursed technique Sho would have
passed away after the first one this
scene is all about the element of
surprise now up until this point we've
seen nanami's Powers in action but this
time though it's through noar's analysis
that we get a glimpse of his his true
capabilities as a grade one sorcerer the
sheer one-sidedness of the fight it's
like watching an Olympic sprinter race
against a toddler I mean there's no
competition so when we witness nanami's
Lightning Fast takedown of shigo it's
not just about the action it's about
unveiling the true strength of a grade
one sorcerer that leaves us fascinated
another thing that makes this scene
special is that it's one of the few
moments where Kento nanami shows his
emotions and sadly for shigo it just so
happened to make nanami go into rage
Mode come on
next is the epic showdown between Yuji
Toto and the formidable
Hanami now this scene is a true
Masterpiece in the world of Jiu-Jitsu
Kaizen and here's why Hanami is an all
powerful cursed spirit it's going to
take more than just one sorcerer to
bring in down Hanami strength is off the
charts and this fight is nothing short
of a choreographic masterpiece in this
intense battle Hanami strength is put on
display as we see a special grade curse
Spirit finally have a long drawn out
battle we also saw for the first time
Toto's curse technique and just how
smart he is while using it from yuji's
consistent black flashes to hani's
constant barrage of attacks this scene
made sure that fans were constantly on
their toes but what makes this scene
truly special is the ingenious tactics
employed By Yuji and Toto they're not
just throwing punches blindly they've
got Tricks up their sleeves or should we
say claps every move is calculated and
every strategy is carefully executed
it's a testament to the creativity of
the characters and the genius of the
series creators and let's not forget the
crisp animation the colors the effects
the sheer intensity of the battle is
simply A Feast for the
eyes thing next up it's the moment just
after Toto and yuji's fight against
[Music]
Hanami this was the first time we saw
Gojo's Hollow purple in action in the
series Hanami was an opponent not anyone
can just be which made this moment
iconic for several reasons first and
foremost Hanami strength is no joke and
the way he's been handling the students
has kept us on the edge but then Gojo
Sensei makes his grand entrance and what
a move it is Gojo unleashes the hollow
technique purple and is a GameChanger
this attack doesn't just hit Hanami it
obliterates almost everything in its
vicinity this technique was the true
definition of Overkill and a on hit
delete attack but as we all know Hanami
barely survives that attack and if he
faced it head on not even his dust would
have been left the visual effects
especially the buildup before Gojo fires
Hollow purple are breathtaking it pulls
you inside while maintaining an image of
how dangerous Gojo is and his mysterious
power
coming up let's not forget about the
intense scene in the movie The climactic
Showdown between Utah and ghetto a
battle that culminates in the ultimate
final moves that leave us in
[Music]
awe we have ghetto who goes all out by
channeling every last bit of his 4,000
461 cursed Spirits into a single
devastating attack his maximum Uzumaki
it's like witnessing a symphony of chaos
and malevolence as he's summoning the
very essence of Darkness itself on the
other side we have Utah who has no other
choice but to commit his life to R and
their connection deepens with a kiss now
that she's empowered by Utah's
selflessness she undergo a
transformation into an even more
formidable and Sinister form her
cycloptic evil eye opens and it's just
like peering into the abyss itself it's
a visual spectacle that leaves us both
in awe and slightly terrified now the
clash between R's concentrated curse
energy and ghetto U Mari is nothing
short of cataclysmic the moment was a
perfect ending to their long awaited
Showdown the soundtrack and animation
were spoton as well and we couldn't have
asked for anything
[Music]
more with the first to reach the top 10
we have noar and Yugi's double black
[Music]
flash now the scene in which Yuji and
noar execute a double black flash is a
standout moment in jiujitsu Kaizen the
season finale of the fight against the
cursed Brothers ESO and getu bring this
battle to its climax it's the big
Showdown and when Yuji and Novara team
up so perfectly that they both used the
super strong rare move at the same time
it's so iconic Yuji and no
synchronization is Flawless as they
seamlessly switch positions while
dealing with their formidable opponents
amidst the battle Yuji and noara
strategized to exploit their enemies
weaknesses as Yuji and noara unleash the
powerful black flash technique their
precise timing results in a devastating
outcome for the two unfortunate Brothers
black flash is a rare and super strong
technique in jiujitsu kaisa however we
all knew Yuji could do it but noara
doing it with him was something we never
expected to see the idea of going into
to a Zone where their senses get sharper
add some interesting twist to the fight
but it wasn't the concept it was how the
studio executed the moment the slow
motion poses along with the black
lightning and the rock and roll guitar
music in the background was enough to
give some viewers
[Music]
Goosebumps coming up next on our list is
the part in jiujitsu Kaizen where toi
she takes out Rico and gets the better
of
ghetto it's a real curveball this one
see Rico decides to go home with ghetto
but out of nowhere bam toi shoots her in
the head with his gun I mean it's a
total shocker that leaves everyone in
the audience wide-eyed after that his
abrupt act highlights toi's ruthless and
pragmatic nature standing over the
lifeless body of his friend ghetto is
left in disbelief and anguish I mean who
wouldn't be even with all of ghetto
immense power driven by madness he still
can't defeat togi toi's sheer skill and
ruthlessness are on full display what
really hits hard in this scene is how
toi just casually shuts down suguru up
close it shows how self assured and
skilled he is in combat even against a
special grade sorcerer then the fight
that comes after is like a clear-cut
moment that sticks with you after eo's
death everything that unfolds becomes a
GameChanger in the story it's like a
tiny Domino that sets off a chain
reaction with big consequences Rico's
death didn't just affect ghetto but also
played a crucial role in his descent
into madness it became a catalyst for
the significant changes in the jiujitsu
world but ghetto wasn't the only one toi
fought because at number eight we have
toi versus Gojo a battle that showcases
the intensity and unpredictability of
jiujitsu
kaim toi's a master when it comes to
weapons both cursed and conventional and
is a big threat to anyone that comes in
his way so what does Gojo do when
dealing with this tough opponent he
ramps it up and blows up the entire
place as Gojo gets distracted toi
appears behind him from the swarm of
cursed Spirits toi's cursed tool the
inverted Spear of Heaven can stop any
cursed technique including santar ru's
Limitless toi stabs santaro in the neck
and at every vital Point possible with
the spear negating his Infinity but hold
on this is jujitsu Kaizen where nothing
is as it seems Gojo is back and full of
energy ready for a rematch this was a
no-brainer but what made it so special
was that we now know why Gojo can't die
this was almost the moment when Gojo
used hollow purple for the first time
chronologically after blowing toi and
everything behind him into Oblivion the
moment these two shared was something
special in our eyes what's more special
about the fight between them is that it
was when Gojo and ghetto were no longer
the strongest but it was just Gojo now A
lot happened from Gojo becoming more
overpowered to toi finally remembering
megumi's name it was a roller coaster
ride that had us going
insane next up we have mahi
versus
[Music]
mechamaru mechamaru and maho's fight is
a powerful Showdown exploring sacrifice
and the quest for power here's why it's
awesome mechamaru was stuck under a
Heavenly restriction for years at first
mahito deduces that Go's Retreat might
not be driven by a desire to kill but
suddenly the floor beneath mahito
collapses mechamaru gives it his all and
fights mahito to the death while ghetto
casually watches the two Juke it out
this moment was insane to see as we're
not only shocked to discover that
mechamaru was the mole but that he
double betrayed the cursed Spirits
mahito was also as Despicable as ever
and this fight just made fans hate him
even more solidifying his role as an
antagonist but despite mecham maru's
incredible efforts and the display of
his Newfound power the battle takes a
tragic turn in the end mechamaru meets
his demise along with his dreams of
meeting mea the emotions behind the
fight as well as the solid animation
made sure that even the Prelude to the
shabuya AR wasn't going to disappoint
there were also several references from
other anime like Evangelion and guran
Lagan and that made it even more
Epic
the showdown between Yuji and choso is a
prime example of badass battles in
jiujitsu Kaizen Yuji is definitely a
tough fighter thanks to his unique
Divergent fist but on the flip side
we've got choso who should have the
upper hand because of his more refined
curse technique it's the classic battle
between skill and sheer force this scene
lets us see how far Yuji has come in
terms of his growth and he's now
fighting a curse womb without any help
and let's not forget the moment when
Yuji strikes that badass pose Yuji maybe
a tough opponent but in the end luck
isn't on his side choso smashes his
collarbone crashing him to the wall and
sending him into the realm of sleep the
choreography the fluidity of movements
and the impact of each blow are nothing
short of spectacular it's like watching
a martial arts Masterpiece unfold before
your eyes this fight is also one of the
few moments where we get to see the two
fighters actually use their environment
to their advantage which is quite rare
in
anime
H coming back at number five we have
toi's comeback during the Shibuya
incident
Arc now this is a memorable and
impactful moment that Not only was a
service to the fans but also
significantly impacted the storyline toi
had already left a strong impression on
the series when he appeared in Gojo's
past Arc where he met his end at Gojo's
hands but he has returned during the
Shibuya incident Arc takes the narrative
in an unexpected Direction the Revival
of toi is orchestrated by orami who
possesses the skills to change her
Target into a deceased person but only
in the body not involving the soul
however what makes this scene truly
captivating is the unexpected twist toi
being the formidable and independent
character that he is breaks free from
aami's control through sheer power and
determination to remain his own person
toi's Defiance culminates in a dramatic
confrontation where he doesn't just kill
ogami but also aligns himself with his
son and allies in their battle against
dgon a powerful cursed Spirit In The End
toi's second demise occurs as he takes
his own life after he asks megumi what
his last name is if toi didn't arrive
the sorcerer fighting dgon would have
been a goner and the emotional impact he
left after meeting his son was one of
the best in the series so far the way he
also took care of dargon was again
another master piece straight out of
jjk
pushing its way into the number four
spot is when ghetto reveals he is
[Music]
kenu the revelation of ghetto true
identity as Kaku is a pivotal and
masterfully executed moment in JJ suuk
kaisen the story of suguru ghetto and
his involvement with curses dates back
to 2006 creating a sense of history and
complexity around his character while
his physical life ended in 2017 his
influence continued through pseudo
ghetto what makes this Revelation
particularly impactful is that even
though Gojo suspected that pseudo ghetto
wasn't the real ghetto he didn't know
his true identity until much later now
this created a sense of suspense and
kept fans guessing about the Mastermind
behind the scheme for a significant
portion of the story however what sets
this reveal apart is that it doesn't
stop at simply unmasking pseudo ghetto
instead it goes a step further by
introducing the character of Kaku as The
Mastermind behind the entire Shibuya Arc
which caused so much Bloodshed this
discovery was brutal and unexpected and
will play an important part as the plot
goes
on moving on we have the jiujitsu
sorcerers versus
daro
the battle between the jiujitsu
sorcerers and dgon is an intense and
gripping confrontation that highlights
the power and danger of special grade
cursed Spirits it's a battle fought by
some of the most skilled jiujitsu
Sorcerers including Maki zenin gento
nanami naito zenin and megumi fushi guro
in a rapid and synchronized assault
three skilled Jutsu Sorcerers launch an
onslaught on the cursed Spirit but the
battle takes an expected turn as another
domain expansion is initiated unleashing
a barrage of shikigami from the ocean
the clash between dargon and the
sorcerers was one of a kind as we just
see how strong the domain expansion of a
special grade curse Spirit can be during
hani's fight against too and Yuji you'd
have thought that special grade cursed
Spirits could easily be defeated but
that was because Hanami didn't use his
domain expansion this time powerful
Sorcerers have to team up to beat
dargon's tough skills every moment is a
challenge for them if it wasn't for a
certain someone they would have most
certainly
lost coming in with a bang at number two
we have sukuna versus
[Music]
Joo the battle between sukuna and Joo is
a thrilling and intense Showdown that
exemplifies the raw and devastating
power of jiujitsu Kaizen the scene
starts with Joo noticing that sukun Na's
marks are still on yuji's body instead
of freaking out though Joo seizes the
chance and decides to stuff all 10 of
sukun Na's fingers into Yuji all at once
it's a clever move that Joo picked up
from pseudo ghetto trying to give sukuna
temporary control over yuji's body now
what follows is an epic showdown no
matter how ready Joo thinks he is
sukar's power totally overwhelms him
despite sukuna bossing him around Joo
doesn't throw in the town and fights
back with some fiery moves it's a moment
that showcases joo's resilience and
determination but reality hits
differently even with this ultimate move
Joo was bested at his own game as
sukunai uses a cursed technique we've
never seen before the choreography and
execution of this sequence are
masterfully done what's even better is
that sukuna acknowledged joo's strength
but brutally burned him both
figuratively and
literally and finally at the top of our
list we have Gojo versus Joo and and
Hanami battle between Gojo and the
combined forces of joogo and Hanami is a
breathtaking and strategically Rich
confrontation that showcases the immense
power and wi of Gojo in the midst of the
battle Joo and Hanami decide to raise
the stakes by using domain amplification
to boost their energy this Choice adds
more suspense to the fight showing that
the cured Spirits are going all out to
defeat goj but it doesn't end there as
swarms of transfigured humans attack the
civilians and in a moment of genius and
pure skill Gojo activates his domain for
just 0.2 seconds and wipes out every
single enemy in sight except for Joo and
Hanami because of their domain
amplification Gojo was just flexing at
that point and we get to see just how
bloodthirsty and Psychopathic he was
when he destroys Hanami to the point he
just a mark on the wall this was Gojo's
ultimate Display of Power exceeding the
combined strength of two unregistered
special grade curses Joo couldn't do
anything at that point as Gojo was just
smiling all throughout the fight showing
us that he isn't a hero who will save
everyone but someone who isn't afraid to
make sacrifices even if it means
civilians will get
hurt
that wraps up our top moments in
jiujitsu Kaizen now it's your turn to
join the discussion which of these
moments left the biggest impact on you
share your favorite in the comments
below don't forget to like subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to stay tuned
for more jiujitsu Ka in excitement until
next time see you in the next video